ja gr euch miteinander mein Name ist
major Richard hirtnagel ich bin der
stellvertretende Kommandant da auf der
beorderten waffenübung vom
sanitätszentrum West des sanitätszentrum
West stationiert in Insbruck und die
lehrkompanie in Salzburg wir haben einen
milizanteil von ca
30% und diese milizteile wurden jetzt
zur beorderten waffenübung
einberufen wir haben da Spezialisten
Ärztinnen Ärzte von die was in civila
dort tätig sein und die unterstützen
unser unsere Einheit quasi D mit ihren
Fertigkeiten und Fähigkeiten mir machen
da jetzt die Ausbildung die
grundschisfertigkeit die Ausbildung für
die für den für den für den
kampfmittelabwehr aller Truppen und als
Unterstützung haben wir dazu in vizel
sperel Salzmann von der Heris
truppenschule der diese Ausbildung den
man in diesem Jahr als aus bildungsbwü
machen leiten wird ich bin der Thomas
und mir machen wie gesagt ich bin der
Leiter der kampfmittelabwehrer trupper
Truppen das ist ein allgemeines Thema
das eigentlich jeder Soldat Sowi das FM
Dienst aller Truppen kennen muss und
können muss und natürlich auch die
milizteile der Sanität und deswegen
haben wir hier im
Hintergrund Stationen aufgebaut und
machen da die praktische Ausbildung in
den verschiedenen Techniken und
Fertigkeiten für dieses Thema
ich nehme gleich mal mit und wir gehen
rüber zu dieser
Station in dieser Station wird eine
Technik dargestellt und geübt nämlich
das brodern wenn ein Soldat in ein
kampfmittelbastetes Gelände kommt und er
sich daraus retten muss sozusagen ja von
der Minengefahr weg dann hat er nicht
viel Möglichkeiten außer erwartet auf
die Fachleute auf die expert das ist
aber nicht immer möglich und wenn es
wirklich ist dann muss er sich selbst
retten gibt's verschiedene Techniken man
kann Metalldetektor einsetzen ein
sogenannten selbstretter der hilft das
minenfreie Gelände zu finden oder das
wird da meistens der Fall sein er muss
sich selbst helfen und da gibt's das
beste Mittel dafür er kann mit sein
Feldmesser muss jeden Zentimeter
absuchen ob dort im Boden irgendwelche
Kampfmittel in speziellen Minen
versteckt sind und das Üben die
Kameraden es soll in dieser Station auch
die bisschen sensibilisiert werden dass
es nicht so einfach ist
diese brodern ein stochern weil
natürlich im Boden Steine Wurzeln hares
Material trockener Boden ist ja also es
schaut im Fernsehen vielleicht leichter
aus was das in der Realität ist und
deswegen s die Kameraden das nicht nur
üben sondern das S ein bisschen so das
meinset ein bisschen schärfen mit diese
Richtung was die Problematik dahinter
ist die Station ist so aufgebaut dass
man wen wir da vom Ausbild na rechts
schauen haben wir so blaue Flächen das
sind jetzt drei verschiedene Körper
eingegraben damit man beim brodern den
Unterschied erkennt okay ist das jetzt
ein mögliches Kampfmittel oder ein Stein
oder ein Holz ja man hört es und spürt
es natürlich muss man aber natürlich
einal machen und das ist e die Grundidee
bei dieser
Station danach wirde jeder eine Fläche
frei brodern es gibt bei uns eine ft
natürlich für und diese Vorschrift sagt
dass man eine fbreite
rund um den Schuh macht warum dann passt
der 4er und der 46er gleich eine mit ein
Gewissen Sicherheitsbereich weil geht ja
nicht einat aus sondern die ganze Gruppe
oder die ganze Besatzung vom
Fahrzeug so jetzt s wir bei der Station
2 im Hintergrund erklärt der ausbüner
bereits wie man gemäß der Vorschrift
drittflächen die man anlegt wo man vorh
Brot gesehen hab mit der Nadel oder mit
dem Messer ja wie das zum Markieren ist
bzw wie die Soldaten waren sie in einem
Auslandseinsatz S oder in einer anderen
Mission sind ein Kampfmittel auf einem
Weg oder neben dem Weg sehen müssen wir
das natürlich irgendwie markieren um
erstens ein mal die Einsatzkräfte zu
informieren wo das Kampfmittel ist bzw
natürlich die Bevölkerung oder die
eigenen Soldaten äh zu warnen und zu
schützen damit die nicht in den
Gefahrenbereich laufen da gibt s
verschiedene Varianten und
Methoden eine Variante ist eben dass man
eine schrittmethode anlegt wenn man sich
aus dem Kampfmittel belasteten Fläche
rettet oder wenn ich einen verletzten
hab dann tu wir natürlich mit dieser
schrittmethode schwierig den zu tragen
und nicht rauszusteigen deswegen habe
ich dann eben einen Pfad hast natürlich
dass ich jeden Zentimeter eigentlich da
absuchen muss und das dauert natürlich
ewig aber Zeit ist besser als wie
Verletzungen oder vielleicht sogar
getötet werden natürlich man eben da
eine Variante wenn jetzt das Kampfmittel
am Weg liegt dass man eben diesen Weg
sozusagen blockiert farblich markiert
Stopp m Gefahr hinschreibt ja damit eben
die Soldaten oder die ankommende Truppe
s okay da geht jetzt nicht weiter da
sind jetzt Kampfmittel da wird jetzt
gefährlich ja Station Markieren von
Kampfmitteln bzw von drittflächen ist
unser zweite Station und ich würde sagen
wir wechseln gleich zur dritten Station
im Hintergrund se schon die soaten beim
Trainieren
arbeiten diese komischen Bewegungen die
jetzt machen ist hat den Hintergrund es
gibt Kampfmittel im Speziellen Minen die
durch Draht ausgelöst werden ja das
heißt da ist ein Draht gespannt oder
einfach lose am Boden wo e der Soldat
oder dagegen eine läuft und dann
verwundet oder getötet wird um die Leute
zu sensibilisieren weil manche natürlich
der Meinung sind den S ja leicht
ja im Wald ganz schwierig wegen die
Lichtverhältnisse und natürlich auch für
die schotierungen vom groß und vom
Bewuchs her macht wir eben so ein
sensibilisierungstraining ja man geht
einfach durch das sind jetzt trte
gespannt ja ganz dünne ganz dicke und
sie versuchen eben jetzt mit der Hand
oder mit ein Hilfsmittel die trte zu
erkennen ja um einfachfüh dafür zu
kriegen wie schwierig das in
Wirklichkeit
ist hier se Trappe von einer stockmine
die eben durch diesen Draht ausgelöst
wird da ist einfach nicht s dass wir
vorgespannter Schlagbolzen der eben von
diesem Draht od Ö Ken wird und WN ich d
dr anreiß dann löst die Mine aus und W
jetzt mein Finger
folgt hier liegt dieser loser Draht
warum liegt der losose da ja weil sonst
jedes Tier W der gespannt werden würde
ja wird es auslösen ist nicht sin unds
Weg ja sondern das ist ja gerichtet
gegen Menschen und der Mensch marschiert
ja so und damit Fadel bei mein drot ein
und das ist der Grund warum dieser
eentlich Boden soegt und deswegen diese
komischen Bewegungen dass mirben von
unten bis nach oben diese trettete Sucht
das sind jetzt natürlich keine
Kampfmittel nichts versteckt wie gesagt
das nur ein Teil dieses Techniktrainings
ja und das ganze mit BR markieren und so
ist dann ein ein Ablauf sozusagen am
Ende und im Stationsbetrieb machen wir
das eben Schritt für Schritt damit die
Leute wirklich was davon haben und was
lernen können und da wirklich üben
können das ist ja das wirklich
wichtigste
ja so wir sind jetzt bei der nächsten
Station und das ist die Königsklasse
sozusagen nämlich hier sind jetztrappen
von Kampfmitteln im Gelände oder entlang
dieses Weges dieses patronienweges
dieses
fiktiven platziert worden von mir und
die Gruppe hat es den vorigen Auftrag
gehabt einfach mit den Augen zu
versuchen diese Kampfmittel zu erkennen
weil es manchmal immer noch wie beim dr
der Meinung ist ja ja deswegen haben
jetzt gewisse Zeit geht dies zu erkennen
dazu haben S auch ein
hilfshandbuch ja wo die Kampfmittel
identifizieren können bis zu ein
gewissen Maß und das soll in einem
auslandseinat hfen dann einen
Sicherheitsabstand einen richtigen zu
wählen und jetzt sagt mir jetzt was wir
gefunden
haben meine sogenannte
schachtelmine richtig erkennenicht
da meine sogenannte ba2
schützenmine
richtig
meineine verlegte
schüzen ja vollkommen richtig erkannt
wir haben da eine panzerminenperre die
bereits geöffnet worden ist und
zusätzlich eben diese fernverlegten
schützenmenen ja genau das ist das was
jetzt gerade in ein Kriegsgebiet in der
Ukraine z.B passiert die Minensperren
werden hingelegt und dann wird mit ein
arerie Raketensystem werden diese
kleinen schützenmienen verlegt Funktion
relativ simpel das ist ein Plastik ganz
weich das ist flüssiger Sprengstoff drin
man steigt da drauf und dann explodiert
die
Mine es gibt Gott sei Dank auch eine
Variante davon die sich selbst zerlegt
das heißt noch sp ist 72 Stunden sollte
diese Mine sich selbst auflösen
natürlich gibt es vielequoten ja aber
wie gesagt diese Minen werden bis zu 40
km weit mit einer artillerier
Raketensystem verschossen und über diese
Minensperren von die panzermen drüber
[Musik]
gelegt